madame la Première ministre vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales madame la rapporteur
générale Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés l'adoption du projet doit de
financement pour la sécurité sociale est
essentielle pour notre pays c'est la
capacité pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens de se soigner c'est le
fonctionnement de nos hôpitaux et le
salaire des soignants qui y travaillent
c'est l'accompagnement des jeunes
enfants et des familles c'est le soutien
aux personnes en situation de handicap
et au plus fragile c'est l'aide au plus
démunis ce sont les retraites de nos
aînés c'est l'autonomie des personnes
âgées le PLFSS est bien plus qu'un
budget c'est de notre modèle social dont
il est question c'est chaque année
l'occasion de le moderniser de
l'améliorer
de l'adapter aux attentes de nos
concitoyens ce PLFSS c'est près de 3
milliards d'euros supplémentaires en
2023 pour l'objectif national
d'assurance maladie
lâ c'est une revalorisation supérieure à
l'inflation pour l'année
prochaine ce PLFSS c'est un
investissement de plus de 640 milliards
d'euros en
comme l'année dernière il consacre des
moyens croissants à notre sécurité
sociale nous accentuons nos actions sur
la prévention nous faisons évoluer le
financement de l'hôpital nous ouvrons la
voie à une réforme du financement des
épades nous renforçons la lutte contre
la
fraude sur ce texte si important pour le
quotidien des Français une fois de plus
comme toujours nous avons tenté de
trouver des points
d'accord les ministres ont échangé en
amont avec tous les groupes
parlementaires une fois de plus comme
toujours nous avons fait évoluer notre
texte et accepter des amendements de la
majorité comme des
oppositions sur cette deuxième partie du
PLFSS consacré aux recettes des
amendements permettront d'enrichir les
dispositifs de de lutte contre la
fraude d'améliorer d'améliorer les
d'améliorer et c'est important les
droits des travailleurs indépendants de
simplifier les démarches d'affiliation
et de paiement des cotisations des
agriculteurs de tirer les conséquences
de la réforme des lycées professionnels
quant au régime social des allocations
versées au lycéen ou de sécuriser pour
les industriels le niveau des
contributions
pharmaceutiques
pourtant malgré nos ouvertures une fois
de
plus l'usage selon lequel les groupes
d'opposition refuse de voter un budget
quel qu'il soit a prévalu nous l'avons
encore mesuré en
commission si cette deuxè partie du
PLFSS n'est pas adoptée nous ne pourrons
pas examiner sa troè partie c'est-à-dire
les mesures concrètes de protection
sociale pour les
français si cette deuxème partie du
PLSS pas adopté nous priverons tout
notre modèle social de ces ressources
avec mon gouvernement je m'y
refuse aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la deè partie du projet
doit de financement de la sécurité
sociale
2024 je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première
ministre l'Assemblée nationale prend
acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution le texte sur lequel la
première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
article 155 alinéa 1er du règlement le
débat sur le texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure
déposée avant demain 18h30 et votter
dans les conditions prévues à l'article
49 de la Constitution dans l'hypothèse
où une motion de censure serait déposée
la Conférence des Présidents fixera la
date et les modalités de sa discussion
la séance
estlevée